catherine came in
that morning
with uh tears in her eyes and she hadn't
slept all night
and she said
uh we're wrong you know for the very
reason we thought we couldn't do this
because we have children is the reason
we need to do this because we understand
what innocence is and what a child
deserves and if it's true
that there's this many children stuck in
this
how can we be selfish and not try
so that was it and then i said yes and
off we went and you know what it was
about a thousand times worse than like
my mind could have imagined
people would be beyond shocked if they
knew what was happening to children like
the very first case i worked i was
looking at this this imagery these
videos of children um
just and i'm afraid even to get i'm
afraid people are turning up the podcast
right now
right because it's so hard it's so hard
don't don't turn it off just hang in
there for a little bit because
if we don't listen to this
these children have no hope
that's it and so we have to all shed a
bit of innocence right to engage this
fight
um but what people are able to do to
children it's just insane
and so we um it broke me i mean i
the first case i worked i remember
running to my kid's school picking him
up checking him out under some false
pretense of the dentist or something and
took him home and just sobbed and held
them i'm like i can't believe what's
going on out there
[Music]
that was tim ballard a former special
agent and undercover operator for the
department of homeland security and also
former cia he's an abolitionist ngo
specialist activist and philanthropist
and is the founder and president of our
rescue that rescues children from child
sex trafficking and sexual exploitation
the selling of people human trafficking
is the fastest growing criminal
enterprise in the world
with 27 million enslaved six million of
them children
so many of us aren't aware of how
widespread this issue is because it's
not in the forefront of the media and it
can feel foreign to us because we think
it doesn't happen where we live
but if people knew what was happening
not just abroad but also all around us
we would realize that this is the closet
crime that is exploding and rising at
astronomical rates this episode is
heavy
sobering and challenging but also
important to hear be aware when starting
this episode that we discussed some very
heavy topics including children and sex
trafficking but that there's a reason
and goal in mind how to protect our
children and support those who are
rescuing children from slavery
we cover what human trafficking looks
like today in different parts of the
world including the us why this issue
isn't on the forefront of the media how
our rescue works with governments to
rescue children both in the us and
outside of it
online explicit material and how they
help facilitate tracking down predators
and finding the abused children his
recent trip to ukraine and how human
trafficking plays a role the
normalization of pedophilia and sex with
minors and the dangers of children using
smartphones gaming and social media
a link below our rescues website so you
can support their mission to end child
sex slavery and be sure to check out the
documentary he talks about in this
podcast that will be coming out this
year called good friday on what our
rescue is doing in ukraine to help
rescue orphans and children at risk of
being trafficked
i know this topic is so hard to even
hear but let's be brave together to
learn what's really happening for the
sake of these children who need us to
care we can't help what we don't know
without further ado let's begin all
right we are on thank you so much tim
for coming here i am so excited for this
conversation very it's a very sobering
conversation but really important one so
thank you for being here thank you and i
definitely want to get into
um like your story and how you got to
doing what you do but first can you kind
of explain human trafficking what it is
today
and i think a lot of people think oh it
doesn't happen where we live and it
feels a little bit foreign and it feels
a little bit like
something vague right but yeah just
explain that yeah so human trafficking
it's probably better defined as just
modern-day slavery um
you know it's not necessary that
someone's
moving a body right and that's what
people think um because terms have a way
of just kind of
being kind of organically created right
and people what does the trafficking
mean
it's the buying and selling of people
that's what it is
um and it's believe it or not the
fastest growing criminal enterprise in
the world
wow it's by most estimates department of
labor un usda department it's 150
billion dollar a year business wow so i
mean that's
to kind of give some context to how much
money that is
um it's roughly the amount you that
would be required to purchase every
starbucks franchise in the world every
nba team and still send every american
kid to college
so it's a lot of money and it's shocking
to people because they they think but
it's
but we got rid of slavery that's i read
in the history books abraham lincoln and
the civil war and and it's it's it is
sobering like you say to consider the
fact that there's more people enslaved
today than ever before in the history of
mankind
um you could add up all the slaves
during that horrific period and there's
nothing worse than that period of the
transatlantic slave trade i'm not making
comparisons other than to say that you
can add all of them up all those people
who are enslaved over like 300 years
and there's still more people alive in
slavery today than all of those combined
and the vast majority of slave labor
um and then sex slavery and then organ
harvesting
and
it's it's it's a major major problem and
most of the governments of the world are
currently kind of ill-equipped to deal
with the magnitude of the problem so
what we're trying to do is empower them
give them the tools the knowledge the
training whatever it is they need so
that they can better do their job in
locating and liberating
people mostly women and children we
focus on children mostly but
um but we have
rescued many women as well as the
children why is it growing so much
there's just this demand you know it's
it's um slavery has been around for
pretty much forever why because as evil
as it is
it's profitable right i mean you own
somebody
that's a let's you can get a lot of
product out whatever you're what it is
whatever you're doing so there's the
demand and that's just greed
um and then on the sex side which is
kind of our focus we have done some
slave labor cases but mostly it's sex
the sex trafficking of children
there's this demand there's a sick
um sex addiction that's going around
this this world um
it's it's a pornified world we live in
right it's
it's desensitized people it's created
brain damage and and so many people that
they want
[Music]
to engage in sex activity with with
children
and and so that's why we see this
increased demand for that right and i
heard you say once too that like
comparing it to like the cocaine other
criminal enterprises that like you sell
it once but with a human you said that
you sell over and over again right it's
very profitable for these for people who
are providing this black dark horrific
market um you can sell a child that
we've seen 10 20 times within a 24-hour
period for 10-15 minutes to to engage in
some horrific sex act
and yeah with drugs it's one time and
then you know
but you you keep this child and you can
use them over and over and over and over
again
so so long as the world continues to
create
this demand and and the united states
unfortunately we're the number one
consumer of child exploitation material
generally year after year so so much of
the demand is is in is in the united
states wow so why why do you think this
isn't like
on the forefront of the media like why
is this one of the things that like not
that long ago no one was talking about
and even now it's like kind of these
things that's like oh yeah you hear
about it but you barely it's barely
talked about you'd think this would be
like on the very forefront of the news
in the media yeah it's so disappointing
um you know we we get back from these
operations i just got back from ukraine
i told you a few days ago and you come
back and you're just
like looking at what the headlines are
and it kills you it's like this is the
thing that's most important when there's
so many children being abused in ways
that are incomprehensible not just a few
millions of children right
um it should be the headlines every
single day and i i go back to history
and think well for hundreds of years in
this country it existed in this horrific
form this was slavery the transatlantic
slave trade which was slave labor and
sex slavery um also
and it wasn't talked about then either
why for the same reasons it's one
it's it's too hard to look at
you know as as
people we generally see like the plight
of a child that it's like
something horrible happening we think of
our own children and it hurts it's too
hard to listen too hard it's too hard to
listen to
and then also
i mean i think there's a lot more people
involved in it than we like to consider
and people in power and people who don't
want this message out
of sexual deviance and where it's
derived from especially i mean
the the science behind pornography it's
very unpopular to talk about this
because the porn
industry is massive and they don't want
it they don't want you to think that
there's anything wrong with this
um but the evidence is in that it does
create
you know the brain is stimulated with
porn similar to drugs
and just like with marijuana you take
marijuana for so long the brain's gonna
not gonna have that reaction it's the
chemicals they want right they want the
brain to give them the dopamine and the
endorphins it's not even about the drug
or the naked bodies right in the end
it's a chemical reaction
and that chemical reaction eventually
starts to wear down as your body becomes
more immune to the reaction so then
that's why someone graduates to
to something more serious like
cocaine or you know heroin
well the same thing happens in the porn
world right the adult stuff eventually
starts to wear off right and they need
the hit and so they go to like
bestiality or they go to children
something just to get the brain going
i've i've i've interviewed dozens of
these guys
who we've arrested and they say they all
have a very similar story like i can't
they say i can't believe i'm a i'm a
monster i can't believe that i want to
engage in sex with seven-year-olds or
eight i can't believe it but here's my
story and they get into and they tell
the story that aligns with the science
of i i was so addicted to the dopamine
hit of porn it just wasn't enough
until all of a sudden i'm
traveling to a high trafficking country
to engage in sex with a child because
i'm so addicted to the the the uh
the chemical reaction right that my
brain can give me
yeah i follow that this account exodus
cry i know you've talked about it as
well isn't that what it's called
actually
they're one of the organizations out
there right yeah yeah and i i've seen
them kind of repost even professors like
normalizing pedophiles oh yeah yeah
they've done some amazing documentaries
and work on on this subject yeah it's
astounding how and this was something i
wanted i was going to talk about later
in the episode but now that we're kind
of talking about it now it's like it's
so crazy how there's actually people out
there normally trying to normalize oh my
gosh sex with children yeah or
attraction to children yes
and oh man it's disgusting and i can see
what you're saying that jump that
happens when when you're in an addictive
state
it's it's really disturbing so can you
kind of tell us like where you came from
how you got into this as your like
lifelong
career passion like yeah what's your
story so i always wanted to be in law
enforcement and i want to be
international law enforcement um you
know i i speak spanish and i just love
working in foreign countries and so
that's so i signed up and became a
special agent with the department of
homeland security because there are
there's always an international nexus to
every case that they work and
but i studied like weapons trafficking
and narco trafficking and
money laundering and those kind of
investigations is what i wanted to work
um and six months into my job this is
early 2000s i was called in and asked if
i would help start a child crimes unit
within our our office
and i was like why me like no like no i
want nothing to do with that that's i
have to say i get it i get the same
reaction
you know people have when they are
exposed to this this topic
so i don't want to do it and
my wife um and i had discussed the
possibility of ever having to work those
those kind of crimes and we had decided
together that we were not going to do
that
then
um
so i told her that night i came home
from work and said you won't believe
what they just asked me to do she said
well the answer is no because we don't
want that darkness in our home we have
little kids and yeah we don't you know
who knows what could happen to your mind
or
um and so
i remember the next morning i was kind
of like practicing my speech to give to
my boss who was a very intimidating
figure to me
and tell him no i can't do this and
catherine came in
that morning
with uh tears in her eyes and she hadn't
slept all night
and she said i were wrong you know for
the very reason we thought we couldn't
do this because we have children is the
reason we need to do this because we
understand what
innocence is and what a child
deserves and if it's true
that there's this many children stuck in
this
how can we be selfish and not try
so that was it and then i said yes and
off we went and you know what it was
about a thousand times worse than like
my mind could have imagined
people would be beyond shocked if they
knew what was happening to children like
the very first case i worked i was
looking at this this imagery these
videos of children
um
just and i'm i'm afraid even to get i'm
afraid people are turning up the podcast
right now
right because it's so hard it's so hard
don't don't turn it off just hang in
there for a little bit because
if we don't listen to this
these children have no hope
that's it and so we have to all shed a
bit of innocence right to to engage this
fight
um but what people are able to do to
children it's just insane
and so we um
[Music]
it broke me i mean i
the first case i worked i i remember
running to my kid's school picking him
up checking them out under a thumb falls
pretense of the dentist or something it
took him home and just sobbed and held
them i'm like i can't believe what's
going on out there
and um there was always catherine my
wife who was always just reminding me
like
as much as your pain is like consider
those kids in that video
and where are those kids
and that kind of led me to
operation underground railroad to
founding this organization because
there's always this question where are
the kids hey guys i chose not to do any
sponsorships for this episode instead
i'd really just love to use this time to
talk about how you can make a direct
impact and support tim ballard and our
rescue to expand their efforts and
abilities and rescuing more children
from sex trafficking and sexual
exploitation they're fighting against a
150 billion dollar industry so they need
all the help they can get our rescue has
made a significant impact in this fight
by assisting in the rescue of 5 400
survivors and assisted in the arrest of
3 400 predators the more support they
get the more children are rescued the
more recovery supported and the more
aftercare provided for survivors
for this episode andrew and i are doing
a special call to action your donation
can have double the impact because for
every donation to our rescue made
through the link below we will match it
up to ten thousand dollars which means
together we can raise twenty thousand
dollars for our rescue andrew and i will
be making our match donation in august
so if you're listening to this sometime
between now and august you have time for
your contribution to make two times the
impact
and i want to take a moment to
specifically highlight their
abolitionist club which is their
exclusive community of monthly donators
committed to putting an end to modern
day slavery ranging from five dollars a
month on up the recurring monthly
revenue is the most helpful for our
rescue because it allows them to budget
effectively from an organizational
perspective and plan ahead with how much
money they can allocate to their efforts
and the members of the abolitionist club
receives exclusive content and benefits
so join the members whose combined
monthly contributions have supported
aftercare and operation efforts in 30
countries around the world and all 50
u.s states click the link below to
donate if you're watching on youtube or
find the link in the show notes if you
are listening on any listening platform
all right let's get back to the episode
most of the videos at the time that we
were getting were clearly from overseas
even though there's an abundance of
production in the united states but at
that time what we were receiving was
overseas and it was like how do we get
to them
they live in these countries where
probably very little or nothing is being
done on the law enforcement side
and um and then the laws changed in 2006
and that kind of really elevated my
my vision the laws changed for the first
time the united states could investigate
and prosecute
sex tourists american men traveling to
foreign countries engaging in sex with
children overseas we could hold them
accountable as if they had committed
that crime on u.s soil it was called the
adam walsh child protect act
um
before that we couldn't we had to i mean
before that you had to prove that the
the american sex tourists like had the
intent to do it while standing on u.s
soil which unless they're keeping daily
logs of their rights zero prosecutions
so i was put on this team
and i started doing over overseas work i
went to undercover school
and it was just like okay now you're
gonna go way beyond the imagery you're
going in
and
that's that opened my eyes to a whole
new reality of how accessible children
were especially in developing countries
so i was working in places like uh
central america the caribbean
mexico
and
then the us government accidentally was
like torturing me right because
they let me go in these operations and
we'd find the kids almost every time
but i had to find the american
and with budgetary restraints and things
like he was like you have two weeks
or a week and a half and i'm like i
found the kids and the and the bad guys
think i'm the buyer like yeah but
where's the american i i don't know he's
not here yet i'm looking come home but
the kids oh my gosh and it's like they
can't redo the case like i'm the guy i'm
the guy they trust the bad guys trust
and so
several of those cases i'm having to
walk away from them
and then finally in 2012 i was working a
case two cases one in haiti and one in
columbia one was looking for a little
american boy who was of haitian descent
who had been kidnapped and trafficked in
haiti
and i was trying to make that a us case
and then a case in colombia where i was
really down to consult on an
investigation
and train instead i kind of made myself
i i i committed myself way beyond what i
was authorized to do
and we organized this whole big
operation that we were going to rescue
over 100 kids so both those cases i was
told and rightfully so like i don't
blame my bosses i would have told myself
the same thing tim this is not a us case
i'm sorry you've
committed and i even told the boy's
father i will never stop until you find
your son you know um so those two cases
were pending in 2012 and i was told to
walk away wow and then i was like what
do i do and that's when catherine was
like do you think you could rescue kids
if you stayed i said yes i know we could
but
i ca i don't have authority and she's
she's like quit under like what you were
working with right quit let's start it
let's start uh private we'll do it
privately
wow and it was a crazy leap of faith
december of 2013 is when this happened
and i was scared to death and we just
leaped and um the uh the author radio
broadcaster glenn beck was a friend
well
an acquaintance we're super close now
but at the time
i was on a show because of a book i
wrote about history it had nothing to do
with trafficking right
i reached out to him and kind of told
him
hey i have this idea and he funded us
for the two operations wow and they were
super successful one of the operations
yielded we rescued 26 children didn't
find a little boy
um but i found two children who we end
up adopting so wow and then the other
case was in columbia we ended up
rescuing over 120
women and children
um and there's a feature film
actually coming out about that story
called sound of freedom
uh so that's that's it and that was the
beginning of operation underground
railroad and today we're in 30 countries
we've worked in 30 countries we've
worked in every state united states and
we provide equipment technology training
undercover
operations whatever they need we we
serve law enforcement and after care
services around the world to empower
them so that they can do their jobs wow
that's incredible i mean i can imagine
how frustrated that'd be like to be
doing your job and you're like i got
this i can i can help these kids and
then based on your job restrictions like
you had to walk away i was horrible it
was horrible but i never thought i could
sustain it myself like because
that's a lot of money yeah you need
teams
oh these operations are like they could
be 50 100 or more thousand dollars to
hold you know and it's like where am i
going to get that kind of money right
and and like i looked up the statistics
of starting a non-profit it was like
scared me to death it was like
like less than five percent make it past
the first year less than three percent
make it past the second year wow and i
got six kids at the time and i'm like
this is crazy i have a really solid
stable job yeah and it was but it was it
was catherine really my wife who was
just like but how are you gonna meet
your maker
like do you think you can rescue these
kids yes
how are you gonna go back and meet your
maker and say i didn't do it
and and
and that was really the thing that was
like no you're right this life is so
short
we have to do what's right no matter
what and and that's that's what started
this it's amazing what what was like
your aha moment other than that
experience where you realized that you
want to do this as a lifelong mission
rather than just like a job so it was a
really specific moment it's depicted in
the film uh i told you about this coming
up this october i believe
um what happened was it was the first
time it was in 2006 it was the first
time that and i've been working
in this child crimes anti-trafficking
unit for a couple years but mostly what
we did was the um the end user of child
exploitation material or what we used to
call child pornography
we don't call that anymore because
most of us feel like that's too light
it's it's it's
darker than that
um and um
it was the first time that
i had
seen a child that we had rescued a child
that i had seen in a video
and it was a little boy from mexico who
an american man named earl buchanan
had he was
charged with kidnapping him and others
um he would take these kids and he had a
studio up in up in san bernardino
california he had a studio inside his
house where he would film
him engaging in sexual activity with
these kids
and so when i
he came across this
the the southern border and through the
call mexico california
and i was called to the case and was
there and saw this little boy that was
being held in this van
and when i saw him i thought oh my gosh
i
i know this kid
wow
and
it was
it was devastating in some ways and
beautiful in other ways right um
i remember at at one point um well
because we're interviewing this little
boy and he's telling me about his sister
who this guy had also taken and where
was she
so we started it was july 3rd 2006. i
remember this because the next day with
the fourth of july and had to cancel our
plan or i wasn't going to be able to be
with my family we ended up doing a
search warrant on the guy's
place on the july 4th on independence
day where the symbolism wasn't lost on
us
and that's when we discovered that there
were 12 other kids
who he had control of in different ways
like on the compound yes like he would
sometimes there sometimes out he would
he would go to um
undocumented families
who he he was a landlord of he owned a
lot of properties and he would he would
give them like discounts whatever but he
would give him a threat like your kids
have to come to my home every weekend
or else i'm going to call the
immigration
oh my gosh so he would put people in
that situation that's so disgusting and
so he got access to these kids
and
it was that moment
when it was just one particular moment i
was we
were coming home from san bernardino
and
i was trying to find we were looking for
the the sister and you know they've been
trafficked although from mexico to you
know that's it's a lengthy story
um
and i had to come back and see the kid
uh to to interview him further and see
how he was doing and and i remember
thinking i don't want to go i don't want
to go i remember there's two off ramps
in in the town i lived in navel central
california that i was it's a small town
right so the fourth street was his
the betty mcneese center where he was
being
where he was residing an aftercare home
run by the county and then my my house
was the very next off ramp called
dogwood and i remember thinking i was
playing this game with myself i was like
i can't do this i i
if i don't turn on four street to see
this kid and i go home that's me
signaling i am going to quit i'm
quitting i'll go do sell real estate
with my family or whatever
i can't do this
and something like
just forced that hand and turned off on
fourth street
and it was like this fateful decision
because when i went to see the kid
um it's then that he opened up to me for
the first time and i sat down with him
how are you doing buddy you know we're
talking and
and he just in the middle of the
conversation he just stops and runs over
to me like almost like
it was almost unnatural it's like
shocking like what are you doing like he
runs over to me and just grabs me and
he's shaking and he's just sobbing
and he says to me and he's five years
old i mean you have you know what a
five-year-old is like oh my gosh a
five-year-old wouldn't shouldn't ever
have to say this
and he he said to me i don't belong here
and
and i knew what he was talking about
but for a five-year-old to say i don't
belong here like
you know i
i belong with a family i belong with you
know i don't belong in the in in the
clutches of this monster and because he
didn't know exactly what was can happen
next or what his fate was going to be
right
and and then he um he gives me this
necklace
okay his sister had given it to him
and um
i was trying to i was trying to
you know i was thinking no this this is
yours your sister wants you to have this
um it was like a rosary to them it was
this little necklace that said um man of
god and his sister would give it to him
like as if like you know be brave we're
both going through something really
tragic here
she was she was 12 and he was five
and um
and he gave it to me and he's like you
have to have this i'm like no no you
keep it you know
i ended up with it and i ended up going
home that night
and
i i remember um
it was like
i'm either gonna dedicate everything to
this
or
there's no middle ground anymore it's
i'm in too deep like i have to just go
full into this and accept all the
consequences that come with it
or i got i have to i have to quit and it
was like this moment with this kid that
that
i knew what i had to do and then i
realized the necklace actually one of my
own children pointed out hey dad your
name's on the necklace i'm like what
you know i had told my son that he was i
think he was about seven or eight years
old himself you know and he i told him
that this little boy came this necklace
he says that's cool that he got your
name in there i'm like what are you
talking about my name's not on the
necklace and he said yeah it's right
here and the scripture was from the book
of first timothy from the bible that was
so it was like you know people might
think that's just mystical whatever crap
but to me it was very significant it was
providential and it meant something to
me and it was like this is it this is my
decision i have to do this
and so um you know years later when it
got to the point where
this columbia case and the haiti case
that necklace meant everything to me and
that story meant everything to me
because i remember i made a promise to
myself to my family to my god like
this is what i'm doing and if the right
thing is to quit my job to
approach us from a different angle then
we're gonna do it
and it really was a huge need
as evidenced by the success we've had
huge need there's gaps everywhere in in
the systems
human trafficking knows no borders and
boundaries you know it's the wealthy
nations have all this technology the the
developing ones have none and that's
where the kids are being hurt the worst
right so
it was such a need and we were just we
were there to fill it and then
what's so beautiful is is
others who went through a very similar
experience that i did you know they're
willing to shed innocence and support us
and it's just been overwhelming the
light that has come to combat the
darkness and the vast majority of the
light comes from people like you people
who are listening to this podcast that's
the light that sustains us
uh and so it's it's been this journey of
like
seeing dark but then also this brilliant
light from from people who who
who love children and will do anything
to protect them right that's an amazing
story and i think you're right when
you're talking about people listening
here today a lot of times you kind of
just feel a little helpless like what
can i do about this information right
but what is the best thing to do
so
there are so many things to do if you go
to our website
ourrescue.org we have there's a there's
a button on there that says join the
fight
and we have lots of ideas how people can
get involved they can
do events like what you're doing like
just talking about it
just getting everybody talking you know
and when we consider again i love
history you know and when when we
consider like how you know it's it's
it's
unimaginable to me that slavery in this
legal form existed for hundreds of years
in this country yes grotesque it's it's
just i don't get it
um but the more important question
probably is
how did it finally end the legalized
form right
and
people think oh abraham lincoln he's
ended it and well kind of he did he did
his part you know in the window that he
was given and i love him he's one of my
favorites but it wasn't really him it
was it was the media
it was people that you know they didn't
have podcasts and they didn't have
movies
but they had books and they had tracks
and speakers
and for some reason a group of people
got together mostly the survivor base
like harriet tubman frederick douglass
and others
and they just got loud they finally
organized and got loud
um towards the middle to the end of the
19th century
so much so
that when the civil war broke out
they got lincoln they convinced him
to make the war about ending
human slavery it was an opportunity that
was afforded him
and uh when he met when lincoln met
harriet beecher stowe for the first time
right she was the she wrote the book
uncle tom's cabin which went viral and
shut and shined a bright bright light
on the evils of human
of slavery
um he said to her so you're the lady
that wrote the book that started this
war
and i love that story because i can look
at you and say so you're the you're the
lady that did the podcast that started
this war or you're the guy that made the
movie
that you know that that that started
this war
um and so the more we talk about it the
more media attention we give to this
and the more people ask what can i do
and
things start moving governments move i
mean
you can rock the foundations of
governments by getting loud that's so
true
yeah it's sorry it's one of those things
where if people aren't talking about
something then the people in power are
kind of like eh but if enough people
care then something happens exactly so
that's why i say to people make people
care get loud post talk
tweet whatever it is
right so okay
can you walk us through a little bit
about like the online explicit material
like in america what do you do how do
you catch predators how do you how do
you follow the trail what's what's the
timeline
so
you're talking about specifically
because there's different there's
different forms of kind of human
trafficking or child exploitation that
goes on sometimes there's the transfer
of imagery videos sometimes it's the
solicitation
guys sicko's looking for kids and they
go and they prey on
uh
minors who have instagram accounts and
they're not paying attention
um
so there's
i'm so glad you brought this up because
in the united states this which i
imagine the vast majority of your fault
your listeners are from
uh this is where it begins
like if we go to other countries it's
different
not not totally different but it's more
exposed it's more in your face
um but in the united states it's mostly
begins online
and um you you see people that are
preying on children
they're looking for the vulnerable
they're looking for the girl on
instagram who is
is is
talking about
how she is
you know
not valued or she feels
no confidence well that's they know they
can pray and they start you they start
we've seen this right where they start
saying things like hey you're beautiful
why don't you you know i i'm an agent or
i'm a photographer or i'm a
and they just lure your kid and they can
pretend to be anything they want to
pretend to be about their print pretend
to be the
14 year old boy that relates to this 13
year old girl right and then they have a
fake
you know
online persona and they can lure them
out there's a lot of cases like that
another thing that we see
because it's not always just kids who
are suffering in a bad family
environment we see this other thing
called romeo trafficking which is very
scary
and happens
to
kids who are in great families right so
what happens is they they end up dating
some kid some guy they have sex he does
a sex tape
they break up two months later and then
he's got leverage
and it's hey
guess what i have um
look at the video i have if you don't
continue sexually servicing me and my
friends or whatever
this is going out or hey if you don't
pay me x y and z or if you don't do x
i'm putting look oh i have the email
list of your entire church congregation
your grandparents the school
all i have to do is push send we're
seeing a lot of this is like it's like
um extortion right sextortion they call
it
um and it's derived out of what starts
as a
you know a
seemingly happy relationship with your
the high school football
team member whatever right it's just and
so we see a lot of cases like that and
so
parents need to be very in tune to who
their kids are dating and what's going
on and what access they have online
even little little kids this is another
thing is gaming right parents
at least my age and older okay they're
supposed to probably to you but like if
you're my age or older like we didn't
have the internet
as teenagers at all
like and so we don't know what it's like
to be in that kind of unstable time of
development and have to be dealing with
the challenges that come on on the
internet
um and so there's this education gap and
parents don't get it like
i had no idea that my kid was playing
fortnite and talking to someone there's
a message board there's a communication
board right like oh my gosh you know we
had a there was a case in in salt lake
city not long ago where this guy was
gaming with two five and six-year-old
girls
uh from indiana
okay and it was like some little kid
game and he was pretending to be another
kid parents had no idea it was during
covet and lockdowns and they weren't
they're like just play games over here
girls whatever this guy had like step by
step like walk them through how to take
their clothes off take pictures of them
of their of their you know their private
parts and sent to him oh my gosh and and
the parents that we they said we had no
idea this game had a way that someone
could communicate with our kids
and so it's just stuff like that where
parents are just like they have to know
you've got to know what apps are on your
kids phone or computer what games turn
off the
the function the messaging function
don't let them have be exposed you know
to the outside world
um so that a lot of it is just knowledge
can end can prevent the the tragic you
know possibilities yeah and it's become
so normalized to give your kids a
smartphone and a tablet and ipad at such
a young age and it's scary i feel like
it's just hardly anyone cares about it
i'm like does anyone care about this
like this is scary how much information
they have access to and what could
potentially cause a lot of harm but
because it's really convenient and we
live in such a fast-paced world and
everyone else is doing it it's just
become so normal when really even when i
was growing up we didn't have like you
know social media and apps and stuff
like that or smartphones but there was
still like the computer and if parents
weren't paying attention what young kids
could end up getting into
you know is it could potentially be
devastating in regards to addiction that
forms down the road now imagine what
happens when they have a smartphone and
there's all those insecurities that take
place like you're just explaining that's
crazy yeah i mean it's like
the the the the the addictive power and
destructive power of pornography cannot
be overstated and when we give our kids
iphones it's like we just gave them a
pile of playboys like for that be my
generation and even then we didn't
understand the power of it because even
then those pages didn't have really the
power that
videos do yeah it's way different and
people are it's it's really creating
brain damage in our kids you know and
and you know i've got nine kids six boys
so i'm you know i'm constantly catching
my kids looking at inappropriate things
and i'm trying to teach them like let me
tell you what can happen to you
you don't you you do not want to become
addicted to this material and that's
what will happen and then my kids push
back well okay dad how many people
actually get to that place where they
want it it turns into pedophilia
like not not many it's like drinking
alcohol like how many become like
hardcore alcoholics a small percentage
but still enough in this world of sex
addiction that there's two million
children being forced into the
commercial sex trade but then i take it
further to them and show them the
science and there's been lots of
research done on
just you know and this gets boys too
it's you scare the the heck out of them
right
if you get addicted your brain starts
becoming damaged like
there's examples of guys who married
these beautiful women
good looking dudes you know they were
the you know popular kids whatever and
and think you know everything seems to
be happening for them they can't have
sex they get married they have a
honeymoon and they can't
their stuff doesn't work they're numb
yeah they're numb to it because you want
something else it's not a real
relationship you want something
fake that the point of the porn industry
has created this counterfeit that's not
real and you'd rather sit there and
masturbate and look at that then make
love to your wife
and you won't even be able to get it up
there's so many problems i think within
pornography that even if it's not child
exploitation exactly yeah exactly so
that seemed to hit up like a nerve with
my boys like wait what i i want to be
married i want to have sex i'm like is
it too late dad like no no no it's not
too late you're not you're not that far
but like we need to
teach our kids this and it's science
i mean it is you can go to there's a
site called the fightthenewdrug.org
it's an organization that's about
educating people on on the power of
pornography and how it does work like a
drug and i think it's we would all do
well to make sure our kids understand
that and talk freely that's where the
problem parents aren't talking to their
kids they're embarrassed to talk about
like it's easy for me i've been an
undercover operator in the sex world
like this is your job i can say anything
and i'm they'll blush
but you have to be open and when that
time is
your intuition has to tell you when it
is i think each kid is different but
you've got to have an open relationship
and open you know means of communication
to the point where your kids see
something or struggling they have no
problem coming to you hey mom
i'm kind of like looking at porn a lot
and you know whatever and then i was
like okay well let's talk about it let's
the problem is i think most parents just
give them the phone like you said it's
easy convenient and just like i don't
really want to talk about sex and then
okay you're going to let
you know some porn site teach your kid
about sex
and that's not and they're going to
teach them the wrong thing right so
um more engagement yeah we need on the
on the parental side yes and even
there's so many problems with young kids
having smartphones aside from even just
pornography like just the insecurities
that come about face filters which i've
talked about my podcast before the way
it affects your self-image your view of
self-worth especially with like a
developing brain yeah we i have major
problems with like young kids having
smartphones and access to all of it i
understand like you know you're gonna
have a game with your dad you play a
like a video game here and there but
like those are good advice about like
the messaging turning off the messages
yeah so what about um
predators who are pedophiles exchanging
online explicit content how do you go
about our how does our rescue go about
and catching these predators and do you
work with the government are you like on
consignment with them how do you do it
so we support we support government we
support
law enforcement agencies dedicated to to
finding this stuff right
so there's amazing software out there
that has been developed by different
brilliant minds
that has been able to go in and identify
um
child exploitation material
um you get into the dark net especially
and when people are exchanging it
there's there's codes right they can
talk to each other and send messages
and so law enforcement over the years
has been able to collect a massive
amount of
of um
child exploitation material millions
like because they seize it and they hold
these libraries so now they they they're
able to then use that to go into these
places
in the dark net especially and identify
where that image is now being sent and
transferred and then they can track it
and it's all it's all open it's it's not
a fourth amendment kind of privacy issue
because the dark net these places
they're public they're public spaces
it's their public spheres anyone can go
and look around and so there is software
available that's just like it's like
almost
virtually right they can it's like law
enforcement walk in and be like oh you
just sent and you just received and i
and i can now find out where both your
addresses are and i can go do warrants
on your like it's that fast it's that
amazing
um so we one of the things we do is we
find law enforcement agencies who don't
have that
and we train them we get them the
training on it we fund the training um
we buy them the digital forensic
computers the labs like for example in
2014 we went into thailand
and at the time there was very little
being done about child exploitation
material which is
devastating being that this is one of
the hot the hottest kind of
uh you know zones for for sex
trafficking
and um so we were able to go in and help
them build what i believe that is their
like their their first digital forensic
laboratory
today we have 24 25 full-time people
mostly thai national
and we have a fusion center um where we
have all the equipment all the digital
forensics all the capabilities and then
the law enforcement agencies come to our
office and sit down and use our stuff
and we give them leads and then they ask
us to help with x y and z they bring us
on their warrants we go in and do the
digital forensics and so that's how we
do it we support them with all the tools
and technology and we have all of it
all the new developing stuff we have it
and we
we we make it available so so often
there's
um a lack of budgets for this kind of
stuff and what's tragic about child
crimes i mean there's many things but
one of the tragic things is
it's a proactive investigation right
it's not these cases generally sometimes
they do but generally they don't fall on
your desk it'll fall into your lap like
a homicide or a bank robbery where
something happens and you have to
respond right
and someone's reporting it right
someone's reporting you have to respond
that doesn't happen generally with child
crimes you got to go out and find it you
have to be proactive we you know we're
called operation underground railroad
for a reason yeah because the children
are voiceless
no one's speaking up for them exactly
and so it takes a lot of proactive
measures well what are the if there's a
limited budget to a law enforcement
agency what's the first to go the
proactive investigations because like
you just said that no one's reporting it
so no one knows what they didn't know
kind of thing you can't stop on the
homicide you can't stop on the bank
robberies but you can't stop on the
child count because no one knows what
they don't know right that makes sense
yeah and so we were freaking i was
freaking out during this whole defund
the police stuff like
my whole job before that was to fund the
police because unless they're funded
they'll never get to the proactive stuff
which means those kids have no hope of
being rescued so our job is to fund the
police and get them what they need the
training technology resources whatever
it is and and uh and make sure they
they're empowered also after care
services because that's even more
important like once you get the kid out
you better have a plan right for how
they're going to be rehabilitated
reintegrated into society or are they
ever reunited with their family for yeah
yeah and that happens as a beautiful
thing when the family didn't know and
the kid was taken
um oftentimes the family more often than
i want to even admit right
or recognize the families are part of
the problem
um oftentimes usually these predators
know how to pray on kids they're not
going to prey on a stable family
generally right it can't happen but
they're going to find the family where
there's not a father or there's not a
mother or they're being raised by like
an old grandma who's not really capable
or they're struggling financially
exactly yeah and that's they know how to
prey on that that's why we see you know
it's not generally the cold kidnapping
you see in the movie taken right right
people ask me is that what it's like
well the environment where the where the
girls end up yes it's it's not
that's that's it's not too far from the
truth like how that kind of plays out
how they're sold for sex and so forth
but they're generally not going to do a
car a cold like just a rip kidnap right
because these are businessmen that's bad
for business
as the movie take if you see movie thing
yeah so as the movie shows you right
it's like that's bad for business
because you got you got liam neeson now
running after you yeah yeah and you know
kind of metaphorically speaking that's
the same thing like you you occult
kidnapping is going to alert
more so it's a lure it's a business move
so they'll go to impoverished areas
they'll go to the highlands of guatemala
say
and and promise a job to a 13 year old
girl whose family is struggling hey she
can be the nanny at our house and in
fact we'll give her an education too and
hey you can talk here's a cell phone and
it's the most vulnerable oh yeah and the
family's like oh you know our ship just
came in now well here's three hundred
dollars just to
and the families have no idea and they
think that
they're you know they think that their
kid is gonna make it and then that kid
disappears and they never see that kid
again and what's the recourse who are
they going to call
who's going to do anything nobody they
don't have recourse so that's that's
generally how trafficking works it's a
lure it's not the white van that comes
up and snags a kid out of the street you
know
and we do a disservice by painting it
that way because then people don't
realize like like this extortion stuff
the romeo trafficking the lures
that that's the most prominent type and
so if we don't talk about it we won't be
prepared to defend it against and maybe
that's another reason why it's not
prominent in the news because it's not
as it's not sensational for the media
when it's not some
wealthy middle-class family that has
that their child was kidnapped from a
window right like that makes the news
but if it's like a child from a really
at need vulnerable family
and
they go they go missing or they were
handed off voluntarily because they
thought it was quite different because
the story is the kid wanted to go the
kids probably happy somewhere don't
worry about it it's not a story when in
fact the most egregious
things
are in the end happening to them
yeah but the story doesn't fit the
mindset sometimes wow so we have to
change that right
so what is the process of rescuing these
kids then both in like how often do you
rescue kids in america versus
internationally so our work um
domestically is very different uh it's
it's it's it's i'm limited to training
and
equipment
and um empowering law enforcement when
we go overseas they ask us often to do
more like we have a more productive
they'll deputize us basically
and we will be like for example i just
came back from ukraine where our teams
and our partners are deputized to go
extract children from war zones prevent
before traffickers get to them so we
literally are like
driving in and pulling kids out um or
we'll go
in in a lot of latin american countries
we work and they'll ask us to pose as
sex tourists american sex tourists
because we are we look like what the
what the traffickers are trying to
service prototype yeah so we can get
really quick into the brothels that are
selling kids in the back and you know so
it's very different in the us we don't
have that they have
plenty of undercover operation operators
that can do that kind of work um but we
provide really cool tools that
kids are getting rescued constantly from
these tools
and bad guys are going down constantly
i'd say even weekly
with the tools we have out there
one of the tools i don't know if you've
seen this is our esd dogs electronic
storage device docs so these these are
it's a very new tool um operation
underground railroad has
has deployed more of these dogs than
anyone else that we know of and we're
trying we're going to get our first
international dog i think we're sending
one to thailand uh one to colombia
so we work with um an organization um
called it's uh it's a
todd jordan protection
canine protection
where he trains these dogs and then we
we build like we we built the barn and
we we fund it and we find the law
enforcement that need it so these dogs
like bomb sniffing dogs or drug sniffing
dogs these dogs can smell this component
that's in every single electronic
storage device whether it's like the
mini sd cards thumb drives big computer
whatever it is cell phones and so when
law enforcement roll up on a warrant
based on for example the software i was
telling you about where you can go into
the dark net right that leads to a
warrant but you still gotta prove it
you're gonna you gotta prove the guy has
the material and sometimes the material
he has is the only evidence that there's
a child and who that child is
so it's very important we get it right
but they can go into a house and these
guys are getting they know they're doing
something super illegal people are going
down every day in the news for this
right so they hide their stuff on a
little tiny sd card right inside of
inside a false
space in a book and a bookshelf you know
they'll do that they'll hide it and i've
seen it hidden in floor boards wow up in
curtains you know whatever false
compartments in a desk
well no no longer can they pull that off
because these dogs go in and they it's
it's like this glue it's the glue that's
used inside a microchip wow and the dogs
just go they'll just signal right on it
and like do their little thing they'll
tap they'll bark whatever it is and then
they
they find it and then inside that
that storage device like i said it's
you'll find the exploitation material
and if you're lucky identifiable to be
able to go rescue that child yeah so how
do you if you identify the child how do
you go figure out where that child is
so every law enforcement agencies have
different mechanisms one of the coolest
is the former agency that i worked for
um they were just getting started on
this when i left it's called the victim
identification program
um and they work with the national
center for missing and exploited
children as well so you get that imagery
over to them and they take that and they
can like expand it focus it narrow it
and all of a sudden they'll like see
like
in the background a t-shirt that says
joe's ice cream
and look it up and where's joe's ice
cream there's only three places that
have joe's ice cream right and then
they'll see another picture from that
same series and it shows like a field
okay so which joe's ice cream and
there's a field you know and then it's
got narrow narrow and then they end up
at the house and there's the kid wow
that's amazing it's amazing that is so
amazing that's homeland security
investigations c3 that has that uh
victim identification
amazing okay i want to switch gears a
little bit can you talk about your
recent trip to ukraine and what you did
there how it relates to human
trafficking just kind of explain what
you saw and what yeah yeah so um it's
devastating what's happening in ukraine
um this is
i wish people to wake up to this this is
uh you know
we've seen this in europe before and it
led to things like world war ii
right the cold war
but you got a a a crazy man
who is taking over
kind of
a a sovereign nation
if he if he gets it he'll go on now why
do i say crazy because people are like
oh no i like him blah blah putin
whatever because we're there on the
ground and i see what they're doing like
they they can't
they can't take the capital right which
is super embarrassing the superpower
can't take the capital of a small state
um and so in frustration what they're
doing is they'll turn their tanks and
just start blowing up
towns
children we got one report
where
they lit the the orphanage workers
i can't prove this this report that we
got i believe it but they wrote on the
top of the roof
in russian there's children here
like so if you're gonna bomb don't bomb
that right you know thinking that
there's a soul right on the receiving
end of that message right
instead they said oh well there's our
target boom it's a war of terror
they can't get they can't make it they
can't militarily conventionally you know
using conventional taxes get in and take
this capital take the government down
and so they're using terror tactics
which is we're going to scare the hell
out of you people so much that you're
going to have to capitulate and so
they're blowing up neighborhoods they're
just taking and i was there i see it i
saw it i saw it
um and so we um we we're working with a
a close partner organization called the
aerial recovery group
and they we work with them in the
caribbean other places
and so early on
actually it's a crazy story i it was in
february just before the invasion i got
a phone call from mel gibson
mel gibson's one of the producers of the
film sound of freedom and he's he was in
budapest filming
and he said hey tim
if they invade if russia invades like
what's what happens to all the kids like
that's a really good question he's like
i got all these orphanages that me or my
friends are supporting out there and he
started giving all these names so we
start making phone calls and getting
partners on the ground and aerial
recovery is made up of a bunch of
former uh like green berets right who
they know how to work in that kind of
environment so they got in there and
then and then our is now part of it as
well and we're signing an mou
i think this week with the
anti-trafficking unit
of of uh in ukraine
and we have this this mou signed with
the child protection services
so we are literally our teams are are
assigned to go in and extract
um
these children
so they give us a list of like here's
the ten thousand orphans that we think
are in war zone right now like go in and
get them so like our teams are going in
with
i mean during air strikes i mean we're
missiles overhead
we can hear the explosions right going
off and we go in to the orphanage fill
the bus up we have and get them out and
take them to the west and put them into
safe houses there and then where oh you
are stepping in now big time is
we are now going to help the police
kind of do proactive investigations
similar to what i just told you about
about how you go in and find these guys
and so it's the softer the technology
why because
there's whenever there's chaos
there's it's it's crazy vulnerable for
children right because
the the children are misp are displaced
sometimes their parents are dead uh
sometimes you know
so they end up alone and they're
vulnerable to human traffickers and
where we learned this was in
um or where i first learned it big in a
very real way was in 2010 when there's
that mass earthquake
in haiti which killed about i think a
quarter million people like immediately
were dead
which meant there was at least that many
or more children now vulnerable and what
we saw happen there was people started
just traffickers it's harvest time so
they come down there and they just put
like
uh orphanage they'll paint orphanage on
the side of a compound of a wall of a
hot building and so innocent people are
like picking up kids
and and and and two little kids a one
and two-year-old kid were crying over
the dead bodies of their parents
and this nice woman picked them up and
said come with me she doesn't know what
to do with them but she's oh there's an
orphanage there because it says
orphanage took the kids there
um that happened before
the little boy i told you about now his
name is gardy this is going to come back
to ukraine i promise but this little boy
guardi
that was his name who was kidnapped u.s
citizen but he was kidnapped in
port-au-prince so he was taken to the
same
he was kidnapped in december of 2009 two
weeks later the earthquake hits okay
so he's taken to uh that same false
orphanage where those two kids that were
and there's like a dozen other kids
there in that same situation
so when we went in looking
a little later a couple years later for
the little boy we found that fossil
orphanage and we were able to go
undercover
um
and
they tried to sell us those two little
kids that i just referenced so we bought
them in a sting operation now those two
kids are the two kids i ended up
adopting wow so they've been their home
they're my children now oh my gosh for
three years that's so crazy um and we
never found the little boy we're still
looking for him but we've done dozens of
rescue operations in haiti
so much of which began
with this horrible situation in haiti
the earthquake created all these
trafficking victims that were now years
later still trying to get back
um and i'm reminded every day of it
because i have two kids who lived it
so i always regretted that our wasn't
around in 2010 like and i vowed like the
next time something like this happens
we're gonna be there we're gonna be in
the we're gonna intervene
and so
when ukraine happened it's like here's
our chance
we can go right now and we're gonna go
right now um so last week i was um
i was i was there when the operations
have been going for a while and i
decided it was getting big enough i need
to go check in on it
to see how much more we're going to
continue this or not or you know
whatever
so we got in there and we did uh this
operation it was
it was very routine
um
[Music]
they're all like very dramatic and crazy
and you know
dangerous but it was routine because
we're doing them like once or twice a
week um so we went in to um this little
town called chernihief which is near the
border of russia and on our way on our
way in to get these kids who our horses
on the ground said needed to get out
um we just got word this was on good
friday okay so this was just like a week
and a half ago or whatever
um
that's why you call it operation good
friday so um
so we get word
that the ukrainians had just sunk the
flagship battleship of the russians in
the black sea called the moscow which is
super embarrassing to them so in
retaliation like i said this is a war of
terror
um they decided to take aim at the
closest civilian population toward the
ukrainian missile that took out the ship
was and where was it sharon the heat
right where we were heading so it was
like oh my gosh do we go for it what do
we do and we just kind of
gathered our thoughts and prayed and
just all felt good like nope we're going
to go right in the middle of it so we
went into chair nahev on good friday we
found the kids
got them out and got them to safety but
what was crazy again in light of the
fact
and i'm a person of faith you know and i
look for signs
like you know i look for god's hand
in things i just do and
and it was so crazy the first kid that
we found in chair nahave on this
operation
we um
that we put on the bus
and i asked him i said what's your name
and he said my name in ukrainian he said
my name is guardi
what and i was like wait say it again
like i got i had to put my phone what's
your name he said my name is guardi
wow so i had him spell it it was like
just
just there's an eye and he's like why
are you freaking out about my name yeah
so i i talked to ukrainian officials i'm
like is that a pretty popular name here
like
they said we've never heard that name
that's a very crazy unique name that is
so chilling it was it for me it was
because it was like
you know here we get to do what we
couldn't do that we weren't there for in
2010 here we are and to me it's just god
talking to me like yep oh my god you're
going you're trying i'm supposed to be
here
wow that's crazy yeah that is so crazy
and so there's there's i told you
earlier right there's this little
documentary we're putting together mel
gibson's going to narrate it because i
called mel after this i said i told the
story i said i facetimed him from
ukraine he's look at the team i'm like
look what you started man it's like you
you got to narrate this documentary he's
like oh i'm in come let's let's do it so
so we're going to try to get this thing
out by end of may to show the world what
is happening what's it going to be
called operation good friday okay that's
amazing so what are you frustrated about
you said in the beginning that you're
frustrated with the news i'm frustrated
because there's so many people in
including a lot of people that i
listen to and respect that are just like
they're somehow almost ambiguous about
this like oh ukraine's so corrupt and
and again i have very good friends who
who run shows and i'm like
great and they're not they're not i'm
sure they support us in rescuing
children
but what concerns me i'm more it's not
my business really or yours is to get
like the in the geopolitical situation
of what's going on but it's like this is
a really bad person
that's doing really bad things with the
power he has vladimir putin he is going
into a sovereign nation and blowing up
civilians
and taking aim at children
like this is not an accident this is not
like oh sorry crossfire collateral
damage this is crap i can't get into kev
so i'm going to turn the tanks and just
blow up this neighborhood okay and then
try to convince
and and so i just don't there's there's
no moral ambiguity here because you're
at the heart of it you're like i just
want to rescue these kids i want to make
sure these kids don't become trafficked
and so you see like a a bigger
problem here rather than like playing
political right and everyone can agree
tim go we will support you doing that
but i'm looking more long-term like
i do want to point out that this is this
was an absolute invasion an evil act
upon innocent people right i don't care
how corrupt ukraine's been in the past
or whatever like what country our
country's corrupt like
you can't have a tyrant running around
gobbling up countries because i know
what happens to the kids every time
right and and that's just one of the
million problems that comes from from
this and so i just it's not morally
ambiguous to me like it seems to be so
many people like well whatever no it's
not well whatever it's it's it's a it's
a tyrant dictator coming in and wreaking
havoc and and bringing hell to nate to a
nation and if if he's successful there
he will move on
he's trying to recreate the the soviet
union for his sake like this is not
gonna end pretty and so i i just i wish
everyone could just i just i feel like
everything's so political on both sides
where it's just yeah it gets extreme
both sides right if this person's doing
something supported and i'm if i'm
conservative and biden's gonna actually
support it with 800 million dollars i
can't be for it why why can't you be for
it
why can't you be like for an obvious
evil right being taken out yeah because
yeah and it's really hard for me being
on the ground and then i came out and
days later i ran into a really good
friend of mine who starts telling me
that putin's the good guy here and
zelinski's the bad guy i'm like what
what i
i just saw it with my own eyes you know
um so i just i wish people could just
focus on truth and stop being political
like stop choosing a side these tribal
wars red versus blue like totally i'm so
tired of it because i've seen the
children child child trafficking has
been politicized this way and it's it's
crazy because trump put 300 million
dollars downrange it's really there's
there's an equivalent here right yeah or
i i saw someone when you you did a post
that like candace owens is going to
support a gala and someone's like oh bad
choice it's like well what she's wanting
to help end human trafficking like put
the other stuff aside that you don't
like about her like oh my gosh yeah i
saw those she's hosting her gala next
week or two in two weeks whatever
because she's very passionate about
finding human trafficking she has a
voice and it's like
people like unfollowing like okay like
you just unfollowed a group that's
rescuing children okay
like who are you you know i i told you
the story yesterday where i when i
dreamt i i i had the opportunity to
brief president trump
and probably right now there's people on
your podcast i'm turning this off you
see he just said the f word that's trump
right it's just like wait wait just calm
down listen for a second listen
everybody don't don't turn me off
okay i was asked to go to the white
house and brief president trump on human
trafficking i would have gone just as
fast and said the exact same words to
obama bush biden anybody it didn't
matter to me we work in we've worked in
30 countries and there's all sorts of
weird people who are presidents and
whatever i don't whoever's in power is
the one i'm going to talk to because
that's the power to rescue children and
that's what i want everybody thinking
yeah that way unfortunately i i didn't
know it was gonna be televised but they
televised this i was in the cabinet room
briefing the president you can go look
it up you can watch the briefing i stand
by everything i said
and the next day my financial department
called me and said we just lost a
thousand recurring donors we have
something called the abolitionist
program where um it's it's recurring
donors right
um and we need that because that helps
us project budgets because we know the
money money's coming a thousand of them
left
wow and and all because that because you
talked because i talked to trump and
you're trying to help and i'm trying to
travel again yeah i had solutions for
how to end human trafficking with
someone who has power to help right do
something and he was actually doing
something he had deployed a 300 million
dollars to after care and human
trafficking and really his ivanka trump
was the one really the passion behind it
i'd met with her a couple times and so i
was like awesome we're doing we're doing
something this is awesome and it was
awesome when
when the democrats were doing stuff
about it too it was always bipartisan
right it's like it should be it should
be it definitely should be so they're
they're like tim call these donors at
least the big ones and tell them
tell them that you are not this is not
political you would have said the same
thing to any other administration and i
said no i'm not going to call any of
them because they signaled to me a
message that they hate one person or one
party more than they love rescuing
children
from a life of rape
and if that's who you are and if you
just canceled us because we have candace
owens hosting if that's who you are
you are a person that you have some
serious problems
serious problems right that you stop
supporting us from rescuing children
again from a life of a rape
because you
hate some ideology
this has to stop in our country
and it's and and and it's it's it's
going to be our it seriously will be our
end
if this continues sorry i'm tearing up
right now because it's so true like i
can't stand
like the polarization so much and it's
like can we just get together it sounds
so silly that i'm like crying about this
no i feel this i feel very passionate
about it too yeah because you can see
your passion in it and how frustrating
it is because you just want to help kids
and how easily people just want to
look to the like left right obsessive
like who's evil good instead of
realizing like the common goal exactly
yeah and i always hoped i always used to
say the last thing on the table
the last thing on the table
that everybody from every side from
every creed and political agenda
whatever could agree on is children
shouldn't be raped and i still have that
hope that that's the belief
it's just what what happens is when your
side is against it or for it whatever
then you have to be against so they've
what they're doing is now is trying to
make it like human trafficking is not a
real thing yeah and they manipulate them
because one side is talking about it and
then the other side is like trying to
laugh about it almost exactly which is
weird exactly it doesn't make sense
that's not to say the other side doesn't
care about it it's just the way that the
media is portraying things yeah because
at the heart of it even i mean even when
you're talking about putin right like
it's so sensitive because there are like
russia it doesn't mean russians who are
in russia or
this but that but the way that it's kind
of being depicted is just like russia
and so i think that's probably why
there's the sensitivity behind like
labeling russia as this or that because
all these wonderful russian people are
like
behind this and being like well look
we're not standing for you know bombing
civilians and stuff and well and they're
protesting too by the way there's a lot
of them in russia that are protesting
what they're getting and they're being
silenced and yeah bad things are
happening and a lot of times it's just
like people who are in power and the way
that there's like polarization
labeling grouping people good or bad
instead of like just coming to
together in the way that you're
explaining i just i you know george
washington
warned us not to go not to have
political parties it's not in the
constitution it's not we just made them
it was it's devastating it never should
have happened because now we just
i'm republican i am going to believe
everything the republicans or i'm
democrat i'm going to believe every it's
so stupid yeah there's
guys come on every issue is so different
and it's like just
look for truth whatever it is and
ask yourself what it is right and do
that thing yeah and then and then we'll
start making right decisions as a people
and and you know kids won't get caught
in the in the crossfire of these
political games yeah because a lot of
times it tends to be like oh i think
this way on one
political issues that must mean i agree
with everything on that political issue
but
you do not have to do that you could you
could agree with this this particular
and then this particular this on
different sides and when we when one
person talks about a particular thing
and then lumping you must be all these
other things because you said you agree
with this one thing and this one side
it's astounding and just atrocious yes
and it gets us nowhere right i did an
episode called the problem with wokeness
with uh this girl named africa brooke
and she talks a lot about that on her
social media about how the problems with
even if you come out having a problem
with wokeness but then you go the other
side the other side can be just as
extreme and just as ridiculous in their
just tunnel vision of things and so
that's why this conversation is so
important and i can see i think i was
tearing up because i see your passion
how frustrating it is that you just want
to create change and it doesn't matter
who is willing to help right you're like
if someone's willing to help i'm going
to be like let's do it yeah
wow okay so when is the documentary
coming out so we hope it's going to be
out really soon we're trying to turn
around quick like by june we hope to get
it out um it'll probably be 30 40
minutes and we should have a trailer
coming soon and i'll send it to you so
you can
you can post it yeah for sure i will
definitely be putting that link below um
once it comes out and it's a quick
turnaround we usually we we've had
documentaries made about us it took like
a year or two but this is like no we got
to do it now because this is a crisis
now we need people to know now so
so we're going to do it glenn beck is
producing it mel is going to be
narrating it and it's going to tell this
story of what we're doing in ukraine why
do you think the news has kind of
settled down a little bit with about the
ukraine and russia situation
i think people's attention spans are
just like you know
yeah they just okay done with that
what's the next thing so we've got to
keep it front and center and and and to
us really that you know i i weigh in i
consider the political aspects but
really it's just it's just these kids
that's it there's 10 000 kids on a list
and we've been able to get just under
700 out so far and where do they go
so that we we work closely with the um
with the child protection services and
they have homes
safe houses airbnbs
in the western part of the country i'm
in work we have to expand that now so
we're looking for other houses that we
can buy up or rent out and we can take
the kids there with the one place we
took the kids and this will be in the
documentary it's crazy
um a bunch of kids that we had that our
team had had rescued um
we took him this past easter we took him
out to have fun at this like fun game
house you know um
like a chucky cheese kind of place you
know
and uh
and it was so fun that's how we
celebrated easter you know and then and
then the next morning
um we thought we were kind of safe in
this western part of the country
um the next morning there was six
russian missiles that hit the city one
was a hit a mile from my bed
another hit a mile from the orphanage
house where the kids we just been with
the day before and there was an air raid
siren so everybody got under the in the
basement whatever and no no one died
luckily but
all the windows just blew out of the of
the orphanage and so now we're just like
okay we got to start moving
because i'm moving these kids so we're
collecting all these kids it's pretty
soon to be a thousand and two thousand
three thousand there's a hundred
thousand plus a registered orphans in
ukraine it's one of the highest orphans
populations in the world we don't this
was pre the war before the war so now
there's even more kind of chaos and
um so now it's not just recollecting and
extracting now it's like moving them
there may come a time when the
governments decide that ukraine decides
they want to move them to a safe place
outside the country which is a very
risky proposition we we don't get
involved with that at all but we
wouldn't want those kids to get lost or
be compromised by some other government
we have a project at our called children
need families i don't know if you're
familiar with that project heard about
it but talk about it so my wife
catherine started it
and it's basically when we adopted the
kids that we
um rescued in 2014 and the adoption took
three and a half years it was ridiculous
right it is
but we learned a lot about the adoption
process and there's some countries like
haiti
or you know countries that are going
through like war like ukraine where like
the only sure safety for them to not be
hurt is to adopt them out into a loving
family you know and and so it's it's a
preventative action where we go into
high trafficking areas like haiti we
find families one of the biggest
deterrents is it's like 30 000 or more
to adopt international
adoption and who the families that are
that are in that parenting phase
generally don't have that kind of
disposable income so we come in and with
the grant
and the guidance and connect them with
the adoption agency and we get the kids
adopted and you also kind of because
i've heard a lot of stories about the
troubles with adopting out of country as
well and i have like a friend with a
personal experience too about like the
way that kind of women can even be
exploited in that aspect of like giving
birth and then multiple times like
adopting out to you know
westerners and stuff as opposed to yes
oh absolutely yeah trafficking can seep
right into this the legitimate system
where you're yeah how do you how do you
combat that so
so the international community has come
up with something called the hague
convention where it's it's they put
literally very strict regulations on
like full investigations are done about
with these kids before you can adopt
them like where they came from do they
have parents is there some kind of a
nasty business behind the scenes going
on where we i mean we see cases like
this in like we're in africa this is
it's even worse than what you're saying
than what you just told me but
they're like bringing these women in
like it hurts you and say this but
they're impregnating them
and then they're taking their babies
and this sounds crazy but it's true
because we're we've just we've done we
can't
we can't publicize quite yet because
we're in the middle of it
but i can't say it's in africa
and they're taking the babies and
selling them for the for their organs oh
my gosh right so it's like that's like a
very very extreme but others you know
they're selling them just to be adopted
because an american family or a french
family whatever wants a little baby yeah
and so it's like well just it's like
this market and the women can begin can
be getting trafficked
right and and just producing these
babies on against their will
um so the hay convention does a lot to
to to help that so we work within with
countries that have adopted that
um and then we are validating what are
like the organization that is work that
you can go through exactly that's saying
that this
they're going to follow these this law
these laws
and the u.s state department is a real
big part in making sure they're
compliant as well
and we went through it so we know it's
like we were investigated up and down
sideways and every other way to make
sure we weren't traffickers yeah you
know which is great i'm like awesome
ironic but yes yes um let's do it so but
still it takes so long so we're trying
to help these countries to kind of
digitize some of their systems so they
can like the application process can
move along and then find families find
kids and then you know and then
right and then fill the budgetary
financial needs so we've been able to
help a lot in that way and we had a lot
of adoptions in the process in ukraine
before the war
so now we even have a more vested
interest in fact it was catherine was
like go to ukraine go go she's trying to
get me like to go
right just because we need to get in
there because it's not just about
extracting the kids is the first thing
let's let's get adoptions going again
and doing it right and this helped the
police and so now it's kind of a full
court press with multiple agencies how
how often you mention that in some cases
it's necessary to have the kids adopted
out but do you ever work with
agencies or with these situations to
help kids be adopted within their own
country so they can succeed yeah that's
that's awesome we can do that so we've
done that in like uganda and other
places where it's like
yeah we would love that um
usually
in the countries that are high
trafficking risk countries there's not
an abundance of people that are in a
position to to adopt is the problem but
yes that's our first choice so yeah how
do you help fix that i mean you can't
fix all the problems in the world but
like how do you make that so it is
easier for kids sometimes in those
situations to be able to stay in their
country sometimes right yeah we we look
for families we do we look for families
and we work with adoption agencies
within those countries and say can you
find families here
because if they can stay here that's
probably better for them right you know
and this created a an environment here
of
of um you know the orphanage system is
outdated the u.s got rid of it a long
time ago we don't have orphanages you
know it's it's foster it fosters all
sorts of problems but yeah it's a step
in the right direction so we're trying
to encourage some of these countries to
go that route
to do foster care take the kids into
families to homes you know
let them be with a loving environment
kind of thing um which is somewhere
between that and between orphanage and
adoption right but adoption is the
ultimate like
gift i think to a child
wow
um one thing i remember that i wanted to
ask you when you're talking about
ukraine how do you know if like a child
who is orphaned is truly orphaned in
such a war zone situation like is there
a chance that maybe just their parents
are missing totally totally and this is
where the hate convention thank goodness
exists so like
i mean
just 680 some odd kids already that
our teams have pulled out right and that
number is going to double quadruple
every one of those is going to have a
question like question mark yeah who are
you yeah exactly
uh
are your parents alive are you a orphan
or are you you know you know if your
parents are alive right and so if if any
of them were going to pursue an adoption
route then that's where the hay
convention would come in and we'd start
investigating all that as it is we'll
investigate it we'll do everything we
can to figure out and this is why we
went to the police because before two
weeks ago when or last week whenever i
was there um we were just working child
protection
like the group that runs all the
orphanage systems to help get the kids
out right and that expanded into
non-orphans
right who whose kids whose
kids just kind of ended up displaced and
now it's turned into now we're talking
to the law enforcement the
anti-trafficking unit and helping them
be proactive about investigating now who
are these kids
where where have they gone to
um you know we have heard all sorts of
stories
and there's lots of news media on this
as well about
like aid workers that show up hey come
on i'll take you to holland get in my
car get my van i'm a nice guy okay let's
go
and know where i don't know that i
assume they're happy so or maybe they're
trafficked right
we have we work in latin america right
now and we have assets down there and
we're seeing i mean i was actually
on an undercover operation
a month ago within a month or two ago
where um
when the war started they were looking
for ukrainian girls it was like
harvest time you know i was like hey
there's gonna be a lot of girls they're
gonna be vulnerable a lot of them are
really good looking we would love to
have them in our sex industry you know
and we've already heard that chatter and
movements to get these girls now's the
time to traffic them into other
countries like in latin america where
eastern european is is
you know something unusual that that
sickos will want to engage with you know
so um we are making efforts right now we
haven't we have a european department at
our that's already way before the war
we've been working with several
countries with with providing these
tools technology like we do in the
united states and we are now putting an
emphasis with them on finding ukrainian
girls
or kids who are likely being trafficked
through eastern europe western europe
and even into the western hemisphere wow
so we're we're doing we're beginning a
lot of preventative action right now
with all that so you need a lot of
support yes in order for you to be able
to accomplish what you're
what you're looking to do and to really
get down to the truth the details who's
who's who what's what if these kids are
truly orphans or not just everything
there's so many factors that are
involved you need like so much
so much human power we do we need we
need a double or man power and that's
why this documentary i want to turn
around quick and say guys help us yeah
you know someone suggested we were gonna
do it for free and someone said hey why
don't you charge people five bucks to
watch it yeah all the money goes in
there i think i think people would love
that people will pay five dollars yeah
yeah so okay how can people support you
talked about this earlier just to finish
this conversation i'm sure a lot of
people are looking like okay i want to
be able to help in some way can people
volunteer even or can they apply to jobs
even to do this as some kind of career
path to help in the organization
absolutely yeah what are the
opportunities as well as donating yes so
if you go to our website and join the
fight you can become um we have
something called the conductor club
the conductor is like what harriet
tubman was again we love paying homage
to the they're our heroes the original
underground railroad right and what they
did and the bravery and the
and and the conductors were the ones
that got their hands dirty right they
went in and so we have this conductor
club like those who want to do more like
it's like a volunteer but but but um
but it's uh
we we we vet them out you know we
they take a test
and they become qualified to start doing
more more like get more active
a lot of those people end up working for
us like in a paid capacity and that's
what we hope to do is continue to grow
out and we have these conductor clubs
all over the united states i think
there's a couple dozen of them
almost every big city has one and then
you join that club and now you go to
those meetings and you start learning
about what you can do locally and then
we have reps from our headquarters come
and talk to them and so find your local
chapter
of operation underground railroad become
a conductor go to the conductor club
uh and uh and and get involved and then
you'll then you'll kind of know what you
can do like i'm a good writer like i can
write or i'm i'm good on social media or
i'm i can do event planning or i'm a
former military law enforcement i can
come in that way you know i'd love to
get involved with helping you
investigate and that kind of thing yeah
and i'm sure there's a vetting process
like you said in regards to a test yes
very very much yeah yeah wow that's
amazing well i think this was a
fantastic conversation i really
appreciate everything that you shared
and i hope this inspires people to
support our rescue in some format in
some way thank you so much no really
ellen has been awesome and i'm
i'm excited i'm i'm guessing a lot of
people listening is this is their first
exposure to what we're doing and so i
ask i ask you all just look look deeper
search your heart and see if there's
something you want to get involved and
we'd love to have you part of our team
amazing okay thank you so much thank you
everyone for listening and we'll see you
next episode
[Music]